one of the good things that can come out
of a distressed organization is
camaraderie human beings actually
conform close relationships during
shared hardship or shared struggle so a
good leader in a distressed organization
will challenge the people to contribute
and be a part of the solution in a truly
distressed company where you need cost
cutting for example before cutting the
people which is the easy one say to the
company hey here's the reality of where
we are if we continue on this path all
of us lose our jobs so we're challenging
all of you where can we where can we
find the money to keep this business
afloat how can we be creative and how we
spend money and how we make money when
people are challenged to work together
and find Solutions together it's amazing
what happens not only the creativity but
the camaraderie I think sometimes
distress is a massive opportunity to
build strong team ethic team dynamic as
pre-decore and also creativity